what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels
live event that he had like yesterday i
think
um talk titled what do women keep
getting wrong before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification
bell um i'm trying to get to 20 000
subscribers as you guys know
each and every one of you helps me get
to that goal ring the notification bell
guys that way um you're gonna be
notified of all my videos i don't want
you to miss anything
okay wait actually let me make this
hello oh he's cut off
hello how are you doing mr samus hi well
how old are you
i'm there i'm 28. what do you what's
your first name
uh okie oh it's short for okay
okay well what what do what do women
what are women getting wrong
um women are first of all i just want to
say i
i love your show i've been watching you
since january and um
you're doing god's work out here um
appreciate it um
what women are doing wrong is i feel
like a lot of women aren't impatient
so basically women want
a man to have it now everything women
don't want to like
wait or build with a man they kind of
just want the man to do all the hard
work on his own
and then they kind of just want the
benefits you know so
i feel like if women can just it's
interesting because the women i've seen
in the manosphere i definitely agree
with him
um but i actually don't have a single
friend
that dates like a lot older uh maybe
it's because i'm like younger but i
don't i seriously don't have a single
friend that like is looking for
you know only six figure guys or dates
like a ton older
kind of just be patient and like learn
to build with a man
what does being patient mean being
patient is basically
i think women should value men off of
potential so like let's say
hold on hold on hold on hold on i want
to be clear
women should value a man off of
potential how do you evaluate potential
like visual potentials i would say work
ethic what does he mean
so basically let's say if a woman's
dating
uh or career choice a five-star recruit
uh high school basketball player but
he's not in the nba yet yeah well i
don't care about all that i talk about
regular me and i'm talking well
let's say she's dating um the
valedictorian for the high school and he
got a
uh scholarship to harvard but he's not
making money yet like
that's what i mean like date off
potential
so and a lot of women if you were a
father
[Music]
you condone turning your daughter over
to a man strictly on potential
if it's valid potential no
potential is potential you don't know if
it's valid until it becomes outcome
right
your baby girl that you raised you
protected you've kept chase you kept off
the
stripping pole you turn her over to a
man base
strictly on his potential
yes if it's valid potentially you know
so give us valid potential
um see see what i mean is
guys are optimal you often say women
need to be more patient i agree
but when you say that they need to
evaluate men off of potential
i'm listening but you got to give some
assurances
potential offers no assurances
how do you make you say valid potential
well how do you validate
something that comes with no assurances
that's what i'm saying like
a high value man has to start out from
somewhere so
women have to be able to see that before
he becomes high value
and i feel a lot of quality if a lot of
women did that
a lot of women can get these guys that
they actually want instead of trying to
get them when they're already high value
and their standards
are really high
um i'll give you examples with me i'm 28
i was gonna say i bet he just wants
girls to give him a chance
because he feels like he's overlooked
even though he has potential in my last
year of medical school i'll be a
physician uh anesthesiologist next year
so
a lot of women actually are
valuing me because they see that okay
he's in his
last year medical school he has good
board score he's he's smart
so i can see that he's going to be a a
high value man
so you know a high earning man
well i make a distinction between high
value and high earnings those aren't the
same
okay so um
the high value part can come i
understand yeah you're the
the six there's a lot of guys that make
money you are not very valuable
but you're still saying that women
should evaluate on the manual potential
okay but you got to give some parameters
all potential
because okay i'd say work ethic that's
what i would say
um are you from if you're familiar with
the oil industry
okay well oil is found in certain places
throughout the country
just because you go drill for oil in
texas
because there's oil adjacent to the land
doesn't mean you're going to hit
but you still got to invest money you
got to be able to define potential
okay a guy who's going to medical school
going to become an anesthesiologist
all right but that's a very small subset
of men
it is so what about
a woman that basically i'm not just i'm
not disagreeing with being more patient
and evaluating
on potential but the problem i have of
potential
is women could easily flip it up and say
i'm 300 pounds
but i'm working out now you should marry
me on the potential that i'm going to
lose weight
that is true but that's a good point
that's a good point it has to be bad so
i have to see her in the gym
i have to see her in strict diet i have
to see i'm not saying that
it's the same thing like she's study
working et cetera
woman like that but i'm saying most
anna's okay so if a man becomes a doctor
all right that means he makes something
he makes he makes good money
what about the man he is though oh i
mean see
there's more to potential than just
money you see what i'm trying to get you
to understand is
not trying to make every guy be you you
got to understand the market
how are you selling your potential
because here's the problem i have a lot
of guys today
a lot of guys they think just because i
make money i should have all the options
because i'm more educated because i have
these degrees
i should have all the options that ain't
how it works you still gotta
sell yourself i run into more upset
angry frustrated
guys who are stem guys
because they may be accomplished in
their career fields but they lack
eq social skills the ability
to actually interact and get along in
the social setting
but then they lament women but they want
women to pick up them on their potential
that's true so so just like women needed
so
if you want women to be patient fair but
i want you to ask about
if this is your daughter you a man's
potential
if he's a young man yeah so here's the
thing
you're you're 60 years old
55 60 years old your daughter is coming
to you as a graduate from college
when she's with a and she finds a guy
who
is two years older than her
and he is planning on going to medical
school to become
a surgeon okay
but he still has many more years of
schooling left
then there's a 40 year old man who's
already
established in his career
already the quote unquote high earning
okay i genuinely feel like my parents
would pick the younger guy
like genuinely has has the resume
which one are you going to suggest your
daughter go to
the guy that's two years older the guy
is 17. i genuinely
i'd have to ask my mom actually i want
to see if i can get a hold of her
that's that's a very
difficult question why because it varies
embarrass on her purposes as well um
no it's about potential who has the
greater potential
not sure um one guy is our
question for you i'm just you know your
response is going to be put on my
youtube channel
okay so let's say um you were you got to
pick my husband
right and you had two options of guys
okay okay you had one
that was two years older than me and
he's about to go to medical school
okay one and the second guy is 40
um and he it has like a career figured
out no kids
either of them both like same
personality whatever
just the difference is one has his
career figured out and is a little bit
older and one doesn't have his career
figured out he's a bit younger
wait really oh my god i totally thought
you'd pick the one my age
um okay
huh i just got proved wrong i just said
i think my mom would pick the
guy that's like my age
because doctors don't live very healthy
lifestyles
and so um you'll probably be a widow in
both cases
it's just a matter of uh rolling the
dice and
the wife of wives of doctors don't have
very good lives
well i'm saying like they're they're
both doctors though one's just like 40.
oh you didn't tell me that sorry sorry i
should
i should have said that i should have
said that i don't want you to marry a
doctor
oh okay okay
fine the the point though is like
would you prefer like okay let's take
not a doctor someone's starting a
business right
one guy has a successful business at 40.
one guy is starting
like trying to start a business at 22.
okay and do you want
him to but you're not 22. oh sorry
in the sorry i'm 24. so he's 26.
okay um and the other ones let's just
say
um let's say 44 to make it like 20 years
older than me
okay um
that's a lot harder and you're not going
to be in the business with him
no
i just think men take forever to grow up
so like
um so i don't want two years older than
you i want one five years older than
right but like
if i can't choose five would i pick two
years or
ten years no two that's two or it's two
or twenty
two or twenty years um
the 20 year one is going to be less
likely to cheat on you
the only difference is the careers
one guy hasn't figured out but he's old
sorry say that again
okay oh my god
i'm just like i'm the most curious
person you're ever going to meet i want
to know all the details i want to know
what happened why
he's not divorced he's like and you know
has he just been working his whole life
away yeah like
what's the success rate on it and what's
the air in his business
because that's how we can sell oh god
okay and become independently bossy okay
i'm gonna finish this
video now okay oh my gosh
oh my god my mom has so many questions
one guy has potential one guy has
outcomes i hope you guys could hear that
but see you're stuck on an age but see
women have to make choices based upon
men who can actually
deliver on more than just potential
because
you would not want your daughter to be
with somebody
who was not secure
rich or not he needs to be at least be
secure
so when you waver on that 17-year
argument
why what's the problem with age gap
dating
well well that just kind of gives you
like a bimodal
distribution so all the young guys are
gonna
be lacking i'll tell you my problem with
age gap dating i won't get to spend like
my life with you i'll probably be
widowed way earlier than you
if someone's 20 years older than me one
you're gonna have to like take care of
them and two
you're probably going to spend the last
20 years of your life alone probably
women
and all the older guys are going to be
having all the quality women
so that's how the world that's how the
world well like it or not
that's how it is anyway
okay and outside of our country
age gap dating is far more the norm
they think we're we're weird here for
having
young men who are all potential
dating women who are at the height of
their at the height of their
uh uh their ability
if you've listened to any women who call
in from south america brazil
argentina um
the norm is dating me and who are older
see what we're trying to do is we're
trying to make
your potential and a young woman's
potential
be the same thing and your potential is
higher later
hers is now she needs to sell to the
highest bidder
now but i don't think it has to be black
and white
like it could be like a gray area like
you know
based on how far the person is you know
it doesn't have to be
there's a difference between oh your
first year medical school
and your last year of medical school
you're about to graduate you know if
it's if you just started then maybe yeah
you know maybe choose the older guy
that's already established but they feel
like
the problem is you know so the ultimate
problem is what life comes down to being
very black and white
you can only pick one person so i'm
asking you about potential
and you're telling women to make a
choice of potential but you see how
you're having a difficult time evaluate
defining that basically you're saying
they should marry men like me
they should have valid potential valid
potential
but okay valid potential means what
valid to whom
just because you graduate medical school
okay
just because you can graduate medical
school right
does that guarantee you you're going to
become an anesthesiologist and become
financially stable you still got to pass
medical boards and stuff right
yes you do but so if you're a woman
one man is already established you see
this is why
this is what i need you guys to
understand the choices we're asking
women to make
one guy is established and has the
outcome another guy has
potential man come on be reasonable you
know that it would be a smarter thing to
take the guy who already has the outcome
yeah and here's the problem the guys
with the potential need to do a better
job
marketing the potential cause the world
isn't
who's okay okay what what which one does
she have the highest success rate in
getting
the guy who already is established
that's why i owe the man with the
resources
trump younger man with potential every
day
but okay i'm gonna call my friend and
ask her how old
ask her the same question that he's
asking i'm just curious
hello hey quick question it's for a
youtube video okay
okay okay so
you have two guys okay they're the same
in like
everything but there's two differences
okay
so one guy is going to medical school
they're both doctors
one guy is you're you're 25 or 24
you're 24 right okay so one guy's 44
and he is a doctor he he doesn't have
any kids like they're the same guy
but one and the other guy is 26 and
going to medical school
or like maybe a year in which one would
you pick
i don't think yeah that's what i said
but
um they're saying on this show that
people only want like the guys that are
established
like i wouldn't i would not want to date
a guy that much older
no not that i could say the guy like the
worlds are older
but it's not that much older
yeah that's what okay this is what i've
been saying but the manosphere is weird
okay
i'm gonna finish the video now that was
all i needed
okay bye
i hope you guys could hear that okay
she's gonna have more uh
i like it okay stop right there and
breathe you can't just go past that
because one is one my potential is here
yeah
and i got 10 million dollars in the bank
and i got this i got that i got this i
got that
again i'm not just i'm not disputing
potential it just has to be
who's evaluating potential and that's
the problem
because oftentimes when guys are talking
about potential they're talking about
themselves
and it becomes a sales question how are
you selling your potential
i'm i am a good investment long term by
me i'm
i am google in 2005. get me before i go
up i am microsoft before we go public
granted but for every microsoft
there's a micro turf whose job is it to
market that potential
is the public the or your peers
no it's it's no it's the person who
wants to it's the person who wants their
potential being evaluated
you go to the bank you go to angel
investors the amount of money that
they're going to give you loan you
whatever is
directly tied to the potential and how
good you make the deal seem
but there still has to be a mix of both
see it's not either or it's in
potential is fine you keep saying valid
potential but who's doing the validating
hurt her she would be and that's the
problem
because that's that's the problem she's
doing validating
and i agree i think young women younger
women
should look at guys who have potential
but
this is why the whole high value thing
is so important
one more one more the whole thing about
not being high value
because if men recognize your potential
and
see right now we have individuals
choosing individuals no one's signing
off on anybody
it used to be that if you came to my my
house
to see my daughter i had to meet you
my wife would have to meet you i'd have
to know your people
i'ma run your background then i would
have a much better understanding of who
you are
versus on just your resume that's
valid potential but right now we don't
have that
and but the fact of the matter is
what do we what do we use to give women
to validate their potential
since that's removed because that's the
way it's been for the longest
because we as men people also used to
get married
earlier because um
because like birth control wasn't around
so you kind of had to get married
earlier and people weren't living as
long
you got to understand we as men we don't
we don't have the same clock they do
right
they got between uh yeah the first time
of their cycle
and a few years and 35 before a lot of
things happen
so i agree potential but
just as i agree potential you got to
market that potential
you can't just say i'm in medical school
it has to be
something else active marketing yeah
like i work hard
i'm ambitious whatever but you have to
show it girls can sniff that
out okay go ahead
um so i was going to give you a scenario
so let's say
there is a 40 year old well-established
physician
and you have a daughter and you know him
but let's say i'm dating your daughter
and where i am right now i'll be a
physician in eight months
so but she really likes me so would you
say hey don't date this guy date this
40 year-old guy i know he's already
established or would you kind of be like
hey
work with this guy that's not the
scenario i gave you i said she was
seeing them both
okay she's seeing them both let's put
that one
tc in the boat i tried to go with the 40
year old guy
and you were too if you were crying okay
but so what
no no no no no no and you would too if
you were a father
because potential is great but are you a
sports fan
yes sir what's your favorite sport
basketball
basketball sam bowie sam bowie had a lot
of potential
he was drafted high he was drafted above
michael jordan right
hey that quick question okay like super
quick
yeah okay just you know it's for a
youtube video
no surprisingly the best it was for um
um okay okay okay
so the question is let's say you get to
pick
um the person i get married to right
it's like back in the 1950s or no
whatever so let's pretend i'm 22.
okay i'm 24 now i'm 22. wait do you
think you pushed me
situation i want to see if the video is
right about who you would pick
okay i'm 22. and i can marry one guy
who's 24 and he is about to enter
medical school
okay what sounds good
um option two is a guy who is
um 70 22 so like he's 42 and he's a
doctor which one would you pick
i'd pick that of course i don't think
asia is the biggest
will you pick the younger one oh god yes
i don't care about it it's not the money
it's about being happy
because 42
yeah okay this is what i said but
everyone in the nanosphere
said that like as a dad you would pick
the guy that has the established career
no i i you have money and i die you have
money so look for the matter of money
okay what if we didn't have money what
if we were just like middle class would
that change your answer
no i know i don't believe i don't
believe
social stuff yeah so you go out with
your friends and you
go and dance all night he's 42 years old
what do you want to do
i mean i don't really go out with my
friends anymore though but yeah when i
was 22 i know when i was 22
that's a different issue but that's the
point yeah
but i'm not normal so that's the
difference okay okay no i was just
curious
okay that's it love you wait what do you
think mom said
wait wait what do you think mom said
what do you think mom said
she probably said quote she goes she did
i don't think the same opposites i said
i would have picked the younger one too
so maybe we'd think more like yeah
all right i'm going to ask austin is
clan here
okay
okay i have a good question okay
so they're asking my brother
hannah do you want me to ask it
ask your questions okay so let's say you
guys get to pick who i get married to
right actually no melissa austin this is
all my brother's girlfriend
i'm going to ask you and let's say you
weren't dating austin okay
he's out of the picture
okay okay fine five five five five five
okay so let's say you guys get to pick
my husband okay
um so you have uh
option one there's a guy who's about to
go to i'm 22 in this scenario i'm not 24
i'm 22 just graduated college
okay i'm trying to get married stat
um
no shh so option one option one is a guy
who is two years older than me he's 24
he's about to go to medical school
option two is a guy who is 44 and
he is um he he's
he's a doctor say like none of them have
kids or anything like same same scenario
like same guy just one's 20 years older
basically with
like an established career
oh my gosh guys it's not you don't have
to think about it too much
it's a hypothetical one
what what the young guy
what austin okay melissa says the young
guy
austin says what i don't care
about austin
oh my god i'm guessing the 24 year old
the 20th
okay the younger guys
my mom and my stepdad are here oh okay
okay
and your mom said one yep now said 24
year old
okay money or the guy who might have
money might
yeah it's more about being with someone
that's close to her age
okay okay so three said 20 24 and the
other one said i don't care
okay okay um i'm gonna keep going on the
video though but thank you guys
oh my god guys my family's so annoying
they don't shut up sometimes i love them
to dab
but like oh my god oh my gosh i gotta
press play
i think i remember that yes
you don't even remember who sam bowie is
but you do know who michael jordan is he
didn't watch him play
potential is wasted every
i day to the university of oklahoma and
i saw lots of guys who run fast
lots of potential wasted every day
and if you had a daughter or you or
i don't want to say if you're a female
but if you were a father and your
daughter you go
the smart bet will go with the guy you
can verify what he's done
yeah but where does that put the young
guys
competing i don't care about
compete compete young man wait your turn
how about that wait
wait start eat scraps
wait your turn youngster or knuckle up
and fight that's what it is that's the
truth
i care about you trying to compete with
that's the world right
but what about the young guys you ain't
my son
i get it i get it i i get that like i
understand like
but if it was your daughter what would
you say go to the young guy because he's
the young guy would you say no i want my
dog to have the best outcome
what would you tell your daughter i
wanted to have the best outcome yeah so
what would you tell her
i get the idea um i hope you guys could
hear my like family
on the phone um but let me know what you
guys think
in the comments i'm just getting bored
of this reaction like i think it's gonna
be the same thing
um so that's interesting my mom said you
picked the old guy
um and everyone else said pick the young
guy
so let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time